RAJ PARAMESWARAN: Hey.
My name is Raj Parameswaran, and
I'm part of the Developer
Relations Team for AdMob.
I wanted to talk about getting
started with the
AdMob SDK on iOS today.
Just an overview of what we're
going to be talking about--
I'm going to go through the
prerequisites that you need to
get started.
I'm going to go through our
Banner example that we have
online, how to use that and how
to use that as a baseline
for some of your other apps, how
to work with different ad
formats with our SDK, some of
the targeting options that we
have for the AdRequest object,
how to listen for
different Ad Events.
This is where you could do
things that are custom when an
ad is received or when an ad
fails to receive, for example.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about our Mediation SDK, which
is the same SDK, as well
as getting going with
interstitials.
So the prerequisites to get
started with the AdMob SDK.
You're going to need to have iOS
version 4.3 or later, as
well as Xcode version
4.5 or later.
You can install the Google
AdMob Ads SDK off our
Developers page, which is
at developers.googl
e.com/mobileadssdk.
We also do recommend that you
read our documentation, which
you can also find at
developers.google.com, and
you're going to have to create
a Publisher account on
admob.com to receive live ads.
So getting started with
the Banner example.
The first thing you're going
to have to do is actually
include the Google AdMob Ads
SDK that you download into
your Xcode project.
This can be done by including
it using the right click and
Add Files to BannerExample
menu.
You're going to have to add
everything in the actual
folder except for the add-ons
unless you are actually using
one of the add-ons.
The add-ons include some of
the Mediation Custom Event
stuff, which I'll talk about
later on, as well as Double
Click and Search Ads
header files.
You're going to have reference
the necessary frameworks.
We've got a list of frameworks
that you need to use in order
to use AdMob.
AdSupport is one of
the big ones.
These are typically pretty
fundamental across the board.
And the last thing that you
need to do that a lot of
people actually forget is that
you've got to add this
Objective C linker flag to
your Other Linker Flags
section in your Build
Settings.
Finally, to get up and going,
you just need to replace the
AD_UNIT_ID that's actually in
the project with your own, and
you should be able to
receive live ads.
So let's go through an example
and see what this looks like.
So here, I've got my Banner
example which I downloaded
from developers.google.com.
I haven't changed anything, I've
just opened it up here.
When we open this, we'll see
that there's a Google AdMob
Ads SDK folder with
broken references.
This is just to show you that
you do need to include the
AdMob Ads SDK.
Let's delete this one and
add the Ads SDK that we
downloaded.
So this is the one that
we just downloaded.
We'll include it.
I forgot to not include the
add-ons folder, so I could
remove that, remove
the references.
So now that we've got this,
let's look into our Build
Settings to make sure that we've
got all the frameworks
that we need.
So we've got StoreKit,
AdSupport, Foundation,
CoreGraphics,
SystemConfiguration,
MessageUI, AudioToolbox.
That looks like all the
frameworks that we need.
The other important step is to
make sure that our Linker
Flags actually has Objective
C, which it does.
This comes for you out of the
box once you download the
Banner example, but if you're
starting a project from
scratch, these are things
you're going to
have to keep in mind.
So we can go into our
BannerExampleViewController,
and we'll see that where we
set the AD_UNIT_ID, we're
going to have to replace that.
There's a Sample ID
in the slides
which I can copy, paste.
So if I put this in here, this
should actually return slides.
I'm going to request test ads
for now, just because we're
working in the simulator.
I'll talk about how this works
later on in the slides.
So I just clean my project, I'm
going to run it, and we've
got test ads.
I want you guys to
pay attention to
the console as well.
We output this message that says
what's the ID that you
have to use for testing.
For the simulator, you can use
GAD Simulator ID, but for
devices, you're going to
have to use this ID.
And there's some Ad Events here
that we use which I'll
talk about later on.
So it was pretty easy
to get up and going
with the Banner example.
We just ran the project,
we saw it
running in our simulator.
Let's look a little bit at the
code and see what's going on.
In our
BannerExampleViewController
Header File, we define
a GADBannerView.
There's a GADBannerView header
which defines this object,
which basically inherits
from UI view.
And in our
BannerExampleViewController
implementation, we actually
initialize this view, give it
an AD_UNIT_ID, a Route View
Controller, and add it into
our View Hierarchy.
The reason that you need
to give it a Route View
Controller is so that when you
click through, it needs to
know which View Controller
to come back to.
I can just quickly show you
this by clicking on this.
So we're presenting this modal
view on top, and when we come
back, we need to know to
actually put back the original
view controller that you
were working with.
And the final step is to
actually load a GADRequest
Object which hits our
service for an ad.
So let's talk about different
ad formats that you can use.
The standard banner
is the one that's
used the most on phones.
That is what we actually have
here, a 320 by 50 banner.
We've got some tablet formats
as well, medium rectangle,
which is 300 by 250.
We've got the full banner
and the leader board.
The leader board spans the
width of the device when
you're in a tablet format.
We've also got this new thing we
introduced a couple of SDK
versions ago called
Smart Banner.
What we tried to do with Smart
Banner is actually smartly
detect the width that you're in
and extend the ad view so
that it takes up that
full width.
On iOS, you basically define
this using your Smart Banner
Portrait or Smart Banner
Landscape constants, which
tells you which orientation
you're in, and we actually do
the rest for you.
So let's talk about some of the
ad request options that
you can actually use.
One of the fundamental ones is
actually enabling Test Mode.
You don't want to test with live
ads, generally, because
you want to avoid generating
any false impressions.
So what you do is you can
actually define identifiers
that you put into your
GADRequest Object.
We've got this test devices
method which takes in an array
of identifiers.
We do ask that if you're using
a device for testing, if your
device is running iOS 6 or
greater, you use Apple's new
IDFA identifier, which
is available from
the Ad Support Framework.
If you're using lower than iOS
6, you can actually use the
UDID identifier.
So if we go back to our example,
we'll see that in
request.testdevices here, I've
actually talked about using
the GAD simulator, and this
actually is just a constant
we've defined for the
GAD simulator.
If we were going to define
another device, we can
actually put in, for example,
this in here, and
that should work fine.
Targeting.
Targeting is another important
thing that you can specify to
receive better adds to
your application.
We do ask, though, that if
you're using location and
demographic targeting
information, you only use this
if your application is already
asking this information for
use with your application.
So if your application is
already using Maps and needs
the user's current location for
that, then you'd probably
be better off using location
with your ads as well, but we
ask that you don't use location
just for your
advertisements.
We've got some pretty simple
APIs for working with these
targeting options as well,
as you can see.
Ad Events.
So Ad Events are actually
really important.
They allow us to track the life
cycle of the ad, what
happens, and allows you as a
developer to do custom things
when these ads are being
presented, when they fail to
receive, when a user clicks
through, for example, or even
when a user comes back from
having gone outside of your
application because of an ad.
So in GADBannerViewDelegate,
which is a protocol, you've
got some of these ad methods.
All these methods
are optional.
You don't have to implement
any of them.
The AdMob SDK will work if you
don't have any of these
implemented, but we do recommend
you implement them
for a number of reasons.
So let's go back to our example
and take a look.
As you can see here, I've
implemented Ad View Did
Receive Ad, which just logs
that my ad was received
successfully.
I've implemented Ad View Did
Fail to Receive Ad With Error,
which talks about what kind of
error came back for me not
receiving an ad.
Let's implement another
one here.
So let's talk about
what happens if
Will Present Screen.
So if we actually look into
our GADBannerViewDelegate,
Will Present Screen is called
just before presenting the
Full Screen view.
So this probably means
that the user has
clicked on your ad.
So if we go back, we can say,
"user has clicked on ad."
So let's clean this.
Let's run it again.
We've got our ad
that shows up.
Click on our ad.
Our console says, "user has
clicked on ad." We can go
back, and we can
dismiss the ad.
We've also got an Ad Event
for that that you can
plug into as well.
So play around with that.
There's a lot of power there.
It's pretty easy to
get up and going.
All you have to do is actually
set the Delegate on the
GADBannerView to be whatever is
implementing the protocol.
So just to see what that looks
like in code, we set the
Delegate for the Ad Banner View
to be this Banner Example
View Controller Class, and the
reason we can do that, of
course, is because the Banner
Example View Controller Class
conforms to the
GADBannerViewDelegate Protocol.
Mediation.
So what mediation actually
allows you to do is work with
different ad networks.
When you have different ad
networks, it's a pain
sometimes to get up and going,
because all of them
have their own APIs.
So AdMob allows you to use
different adapters or custom
events to basically just use the
AdMob API to request ads
from multiple ad networks.
This allows you to maximize
revenue for yourself.
It's very easy to get
up and going.
All you have to do is hit
mediation.admob.com and
configure mediation placement
for yourself.
As you can see in this example,
we've set up a
mediation placement which
returns AdMob network ads 50%
of the time, as well as house
ads the other 50% of the time.
Integrating into your example
is super easy.
All you have to do is change
the AD_UNIT_ID that you're
working with.
So let's swap out this Mediation
ID with the ID that
we were using here.
And let's try to get
back live ads.
On our simulator, I'm going to
comment this out for now.
And if we run that like that,
you're getting back ads using
our mediation system.
So we've got a lot of ad
networks on board, but we
don't have all of them.
And there are times when
publishers come to us and say
they want to integrate with Ad
Network X or Ad Network Y, or
even want to do something custom
that doesn't involve an
ad network.
So this is where custom events
comes into play.
You can set up a custom event
on your mediation placement
that either integrates into an
ad network that we don't
already have an adapter for,
or does something else.
I'm going to show you a really
cool example now where instead
of actually showing an ad from
an ad network, I'm going to
try to pull in a UI image
and show that.
So let's go back
to our example.
So I've already got subclasses
defined, so I'm going to add
that to this file.
I've got some custom event
code defined, so let's
look at this code.
So to define a custom event,
you've got to conform to the
GAD Custom Event Banner
protocol.
We've got an error here
which says that
protocol doesn't exist.
The reason for that
is we actually
removed the Add-ons folder.
So let's add back the Mediation
part of that folder.
If we go into Add-ons,
Mediation, we don't have to
copy it in, because it's
already there.
And that GAD Custom Event
Banner is there.
So if we go back to this
and clean, that
error should go away.
So we're conforming to the GAD
Custom Event Banner protocol.
We probably don't need
to conform to the
GADBannerViewDelegate protocol
in this specific example.
We could remove this code.
And let's look at
what we do here.
We've got this one method that
you need to implement, and
what that method does is when
a banner is requested, it
basically hits this method when
it's time for your custom
event in your waterfall.
In this specific example, we
create a UI image with the
Image Call Custom Event ad.
I've got this PNG here, which
is a 320 by 50 picture of a
very cute cat.
And I create an Image View with
that, and I actually call
my Did Receive Ad Callback
with that Image View.
What happens here is it will
get put into the View
Hierarchy once this method
right here is called.
So let's look at what
you have to do here.
I've already set up a Mediation
Placement that
actually has this.
Here's the AD_UNIT_ID for it.
So if I go into here and
actually change the AD_UNIT_ID
here, notice that I don't
actually have to change
anything with the way I'm
setting up my ad.
This should just
work hopefully.
So if we run this, we've got
a picture of a cute cat.
So just to go over, I guess,
exactly what I did right
there, we've got this
GADCustomEventBanner protocol
that you've got to conform to,
and we've got this Request
Banner Ad Example.
You could actually give it a
parameter label as well.
These are things that
you define in
your AdMob front end.
You can do different things with
that, depending on what
kind of parameter and labels
are passed through.
There are a bunch of Ad
Events that you do
have to conform to.
So in my specific example,
because I knew that the image
would always come back, I just
called Did Receive Ad
straightaway.
If you remember, I just called
Did Receive Ad in my Request
Banner Ad method.
However, if you're implementing
another ad
network, what you probably
want to do is map these
methods to callbacks that the
ad network provides you.
So the final thing I want to
go through is working with
interstitials.
Interstitials are full screen
advertisements that pop up and
try to give you a rich
experience working with
advertisements.
Getting going with interstitials
is super easy.
All you have to do is define a
GAD Interstitial, and the rest
of it is very similar to
getting going with
GADBannerViews.
The one difference, though, is
that when you do request an
interstitial in this example,
it doesn't show right away.
You can see here, in
Interstitial Did Receive Ad,
you actually explicitly call
the Present From Route View
Controller method.
So let's open up an interstitial
example here.
So I've got my interstitial
example that I downloaded from
developers.google.com.
And exactly like last time,
we've checked to make sure
that all the frameworks
are included.
We haven't added the AdMob SDK
here, so let's add those.
And exactly like last time, we
don't need this until we see
that there's a broken reference
or something similar
because of it.
And if we look in our Build
Settings under Linker Flags,
we've already got the Objective
C Linker Flag.
So this code actually shows off
the Splash Interstitial,
which is a little bit more
advanced, which I don't want
to show off for the sake
of this example.
So let's comment that out.
And let's get an AD_UNIT_ID.
I believe that my AD_UNIT_ID for
my Banner Example should
work for a Test Interstitial
ad.
And if we put that Interstitial
AD_UNIT_ID,
notice that this is getting
called when we define here.
So we could actually--
instead of just calling into the
App Delegate because we're
not using the Splash
Interstitial, let's just
define it here.
Makes it easier to see.
So I've cleared that.
So let's run this and see
what it looks like.
Notice that here, once I load
the request in Interstitial
Did Receive Ad, I actually
automatically present it.
Like I said, you don't need to
present it right away, but
it's definitely an
option as well.
And the simulator's being used
by a GADBannerExample, so
let's kill that and
run this again.
Cool.
So we've got an iPad simulator
up here with a Show
Interstitial Button.
If we look at the code for my
Show Interstitial Button, all
it does is define a
GADInterstitial, set its
delegate, and then load a
request, so let's do that.
And here's an interstitial
example.
You can typically play with
this, you can dismiss it.
And if we look at the Delegate
for GADInterstitial, there are
a bunch of methods which
are very similar to the
GADBannerViewDelegate methods,
which means you can still do
things like do something custom
when the interstitial
is dismissed, do something
custom when it's shown.
If you have some sort of game
play that you have, you can
pause that.
If you have an animation going
on in the background, probably
want to pause that.
So that's pretty much all you
really need to get to get up
and going with the AdMob SDK.
I've got some resources
listed here.
If you want any further
information, you can download
our SDK off the
developers.google.com page.
This is also where our
documentation is as well, so
feel free to check that out.
We've actually got a Developer
Forum, which I want
you to check out.
It's actually me and some of
the other members of our
Developer Relations Team that
are answering questions there,
so feel free to ask
any integration
questions you have.
We've got a blog where we try
to post cool integrations we
can come up with.
Recent examples, we're working
with Cocos2d, for example.
And we've got a Google Project
hosting site where we put up
our own samples.
Thanks and hope you have
fun trying to get
started with AdMob.